we start there with breaking news from
sri lanka where protesters in the
capital colombo have stormed the
official residence of president gotta by
rajapaksa demanding his resignation
demonstrators from around the country
have converged on the capital they're
protesting against the months-long
economic crisis and widespread shortages
and they've called today saturday d-day
saying it's the day that the president
and his government will have to go al
jazeera's manel fernandez is at those
protests in front of the president's
home in colombo she's on the line now
manel what's happening
hello minell
now i'm afraid we have lost minella
fernandez so we'll try to re-establish
contact with her and get her on the line
again uh shortly in the meantime let's
speak to charyu
don singer who's an economist at
frontier research he joins us now uh
live from colombo what do you make of
these extraordinary scenes as people
literally break into the president's
official residence
it's it's very very uh definitely very
strange new scenes of sri lanka and a
lot of sri lankans are sharing a view of
hope at these scenes because for the
last few months
there's been a complete crisis of
confidence in the country in the
country's economy because the way it's
been handled and what's brought us here
and with the leadership that has
essentially been refusing to move away
from that thing and away from that
leadership so that has led to this huge
issue so there is now some sort of hope
along a lot of people that change is can
really happen and once that change
happens once the once the heads at the
helm of this really do change there is
some sense that you know policy change
policy reform can actually be
implemented now and can actually be
accepted by the people that the pain
that they're going through will be worth
it for the reforms and the changes that
will be coming in the future the
protesters have dubbed today d-day the
day that the president and the
government have to go
do you think that's going to happen
anytime soon
well the
last time that the
government or rather the people really
protested there was a big change uh the
prime minister left the time before that
uh on the 31st of march when again there
was a huge uh
upswelling of people's organic protest a
big change in governance a big change in
the people actually the ministers some
of the key economic technocrats who left
so there were there have been changes in
the past so i personally do feel that it
is looking increasingly likely that the
president will have to take some sort of
steps away uh now you're seeing mps from
the president's own party calling for
him to step down now we're saying the
prime minister calling for some sort of
new arrangement and it seems likely that
there is some change happening now you
can't really ignore the people's voice
when it's as loud as this when it's as
united as this so i do think there is
change coming and it's up to us to hope
and you know make sure that that change
will really do lead to an actual change
in the policies actually change in
reform how much of the blame for sri
lanka's current economic woes uh to the
president and his family uh bear here
so sri lanka's economy was always quite
fragile we had issues without a bunch of
deaths since we had issues with our
current account for a while but it's
with the graph of president and part of
those issues were exacerbated by
positive decisions taken over the last
15 20 years by the president's family
primarily uh his brother when he was uh
president that is mahindra rajapaksa but
over the last few years as this
government came in and this president
came in plenty of policy actions was
taken that significantly worsened the
underlying economic fragility of the
country made and really barreled the
country down to where we are right now
that includes massive tax cuts uh
between the countries already having low
tax revenue talk about printing
trillions of rupees into the economy
when tax revenue was low you're talking
about lots of these white elephant
projects that didn't really add a lot to
the economy potential of the country so
you had a lot of things so i do think
there is a significant part of the blame
does good president and his family not
all of it of course the country's
underlying economic structural
adjustments come from the before them
but they definitely have a place in
continuing that but you know
perpetrating that and also more recently
making those problems significantly
worse um earlier uh today police fired
tear gas at the the protesters outside
the president's home but um
these protests have been largely violent
free at least today
what can we read into that
well the protests have con since the
31st of march when this participle was
really swelled up there were protests
before that as well have been almost
entirely non-violent there have been
only one key instance where that changed
and that was on may 8 when
supporters of the prime minister
essentially government-backed groups
attacked those special protesters and
there was uh quite a lot of pushback so
outside of that day and a lot of
violence that did pop up that day uh the
protests in sri lanka have consistently
continuously been very peaceful so i
think it comes from the fact that these
are very much
pure run-of-the-mill everyday sri
lankans looking at what's happening in
the economic situation and saying i
can't deal with this anymore the people
who brought us here have to go there has
to be some sort of change and it's
coming from that rather than any other
form of organized or any other form of
you know more violent elements coming in
so i think that more organic more united
nature of the protests do read into the
fact that they have continuously
consistently been very uh non-violent
despite of course very heavy-handed
response at times from the state good to
talk to you so many thanks for being
with us charlie you
singer there in colombo uh let's bring
it out to sierra minil fernandez then
who's on the line uh from colombo she's
outside the president's official
residence minell what's happening
are considering there
official there's uh obviously within the
lord
this world of people could not be kept
behind the barricade they had vowed to
come to colombo to sit in to surround
the president's house and basically
make him go now he has been forced uh to
flee that special residence we're
hearing that uh we don't know where he
has been evacuated to and in the
meantime we're also hearing that the
prime minister has now called for a
special all-party leaders conference and
asked for parliament to be summoned now
where i am i mean there are tens of
thousands of people milling about this
is where you have the president's
residence the president's house which uh
the president's official office uh which
is where for the last three months there
has been this concerted and long drawn
campaign uh called protago home and uh
right now the reason you're hearing me
down the phone line is because the
authorities seem to have jammed the data
signal so we can't actually send out
video live video we're only restricted
to the phone
but we hear that even some of the
protesters
are sampling the swimming pool in the
president's official residence and
that's the extent to which people have
sort of overrun that official residence
uh an old ancestral property but people
here are just letting into this center
of emotion where they absolutely fed up
without food uh without gas without fuel
and saying enough is enough we want our
futures back
i'll just
reporting live from outside uh
president uh gotta buy us uh gotcha by
roger pax's uh residence
uh in colombo many thanks indeed middle